diese unglaublich cremige Pasta braucht
nur drei Zutaten
wir machen Spaghetti Cargo epipe und die
drei Zutaten sind Pfeffer Pecorino und
Nudeln während unsere Nudeln kochen
reiben wir ein bisschen Pfeffer in die
Pfanne der darf ruhig grob sein sollen
wir den Pfeffer jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen ohne Öl angetoastet und jetzt
gehen wir Öl dazu so dass der ganze
Boden bedeckt ist und uns der Pfeffer
nicht verbrennt 3 Minuten bevor die
Nudeln al dente sind holen wir sie raus
und geben sie mit in die Pfanne direkt
mit Nudelwasser in Bewegung halten das
nichts anbrennt unser Ziel ist dass wir
jetzt quasi die Nudeln in der Pfanne al
dente kochen und schon eine Emulsion aus
Olivenöl und Nudelwasser bekommen das
ganze sieht so aus und wir haben noch
nicht mal Käse drin Leute ein bisschen
runter mit der Hitze und ich fange schon
mal an meinem Pecorino zu reiben wenn
das alles abgekühlt ist geben wir
unseren Käse dazu und jetzt können wir
einmischen und dabei zusehen wie die
Nudeln wunderschön cremig werden guckt
euch diese Cremigkeit an das hier sind
echte Katze